hey what's up welcome back to the samuel
and amanda show
my name's samuel i'm amanda and this is
where we talk about money
marriage and life so we've been having a
pretty busy week right now it has been
really busy this week
we're in a different environment a
different surrounding as well so right
now we are at ribsford house
i was gonna say let them guess but
anyway oh well sorry i let the cat have
a bag
we've been we've been together or we've
been in a lot of different properties
um in fact we literally have just put
two offers forward
we have some properties in a very well
sought after
area uh off-market deals in beckons
field which is where we live
which is really really really exciting
so we've been
frantically viewing houses having lunch
in the sunshine do you reckon we'll get
any any of those offers that we put
forward oh
i don't know because i don't think so we
put forward cheeky offers like
to the point where the owners were
offended you know
to the point where you made me call them
that wasn't why though
that wasn't one that was my theory
do you know what amanda i think you
should ring and make the offers so
i mean there must there must be yeah
so we'll we'll see what happens with
that so anyway
um what else what else have we done we
went to cumbria we stayed at
um one of your students patricia kilty's
um service accommodation
property um in the lake district it was
so lovely
it was just like the kids when we got
there were running around they just
loved it so much the house was so
spacious
it was nice to get into a different you
know
environment yeah so we went there just
for two days yeah to be fair it was two
days worth of driving
just to get there but it was worth it
and it was really nice because it was we
were the first
guests at one of my students houses i
always like it when my students get
deals get property deals
i like to support the best way that i
can but then in the same way
i kind of went to show support but
actually it turned into a holiday and
the house was amazing there was a hot
tub
people are paying crazy money to stay
there
like 900 pounds a night so
it was it was something so we're back
now we're viewing houses and back to
talk to you
about what's going on so we have some
questions again how we
how we run this how we how we roll on
the samuel and amanda show is
we take questions from you about
anything at all whether it be about
marriage relationships money um
life so let's see what we have got so
okay
this was a question from curtis richards
he says i have a question about the
positive mindset section
i myself suffer with depression and
anxiety i've tried before just working
on myself
and i've managed to get better a little
bit before my question is
how you manage to get better or help
when you are
constantly surrounded by a negative
atmosphere
and negative surroundings oh
i'd probably say that you just have to
not be surrounded by that so remove
yourself from that situation and be
put yourselves in put yourself in a
position where you're around more
positive people yeah and also learn to
tune out the negativity because there's
always going to be negativity
anyway just generally so if you just
if you do hear something that doesn't
make you feel happy or you know just
negative then
do your best to just think okay maybe
that's your truth but it's not mine and
you know
you've had some negative friends haven't
you yep
what about the time when i don't know
whether it's two persons
oh you've gone there now
it's not really bad but you had a friend
didn't you that said that you
wouldn't have kids by the age of 30 or
something like that yeah
awesome like or you said and this was
when you were single
yeah so before we were together properly
i think we just started dating
and and and they were talking about
their life goals and plans and
she wanted to have kids in her twenties
and i can't remember
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and and yeah my
friend just commented
said like oh no that won't happen and i
was just like for me that was like a
really big thing because it was like
okay first of all
i'm saying what i want this is my goal
and
you saying that is negative i don't like
people speaking negative things
over me so for me i was just like no i
rebuked that that's maybe
that's for you but it's not for me so i
just yeah
in that moment i was just like well no
that's that's not what's gonna happen to
me so and here we are a few years like
three kids three kids and you're there
how old are you now i'm training
28. i remember as well a guy came up to
another you remember this a guy came up
to me in the street
literally walked up to me do you
remember the story i think i think i
know
walked up to me in the street and he
said um
you will never be able to have children
yeah
at the blue i'm like wow no we
we hadn't had we didn't have kids we
just got married
really angry guy yeah just walked up to
me i don't know what
i don't i think he said i think i think
there was a lot of people watching it
was at the
in london and people were pushing fast
and he he thought i'd pushed him or
shoved me yeah
ridiculous and then you know nothing
happened as far as i was concerned we
didn't even accidentally knock into each
other nothing i might have just touched
his
i don't know but then he just and then
like later he just walked up to
to meet a man and he looks really good
you never have children
and and i remember just thinking you
know what a strange thing
to say what a horrible thing what a
horrible thing to say but i didn't give
it
any thought um i didn't dwell on it but
that's the kind of thing as well when
you're around negative people
you can sometimes someone can just say
something a mean comment or a nasty
prophecy of your life and you can just
dwell on it and think about it
but i think you just need to drop that
stuff like a hot potato
drop it like it's hot i mean especially
if you're online like the amount of
negativity that i get
even amanda gets people people really
nasty stuff like
even when you're pregnant what is it
with kids
people saying you're going to miss carol
you're going to miscarry what
horrible horrible things that people say
online for no reason
you know i'd say definitely just don't
focus on it and drop it remove yourself
from the situation if you can
it only has the power that you give it
yeah not to
not to excuse it so my advice to you is
if you're around negative people
just disconnect from them and there's
some people that you can't disconnect
from because maybe they are
your brother or your mom or whatever so
there's
some people that you can spend two
hours with but not two days with
yeah there's some people you can spend
two minutes with so i think
yeah disconnect drop it like it's hot
surround yourself with
happy people that support you and want
you to win
so true so true okay uh someone says
um you've explained how you met but
please can you describe what happened on
your very first date
okay on our very first date so just set
the context for the first date
cool amanda you're born and bred in
harare zimbabwe yeah but you were living
in leeds and when we met she told me oh
i'm living in leeds and i was like
firstly i was like what a coincidence
that's my name you know she's like
right but um i think i said to you
if i am up north yeah oh
do you remember our first date that
didn't happen yeah okay so yeah there
was
there was a day the first day that
didn't actually happen terrible and what
happened was
because samuel knew i was from leeds he
saw that there was a miley cyrus concert
on and it was when she was doing her
bangers tour
amazing and samuel said to me oh would
you like to
would you like to go to watch miley
cyrus with me and i
thought what i i just assumed
that he had tickets and someone had
blown him off and then he was asking me
just as a backup just because i happen
to live in leeds which is near the arena
so i just kind of thought but he
actually from his perspective
you'd said that he was going to get the
tickets for us to go and see because he
just thought it'd be fun
so um that was the first date that never
actually happened so i kind of got stood
up
and i also i'm so good because that
album that miley did
the bangers album was banging um and i
just thought like
you know that might be nice but that
didn't happen so instead i
struck again and uh in fact it was
manchester
i i said hey i'm going to be in the area
do you want to do something in
manchester
yeah we agreed to meet and what what
happened on the day on the day
we spent the day together so we met we
had literally breakfast lunch and dinner
together that day
yeah we met um in piccadilly gardens in
manchester
and we went for a coffee first in coffee
in
um cafe nera and oh wow you're very
remember
every dvd yeah yeah yeah i went to cafe
nera and i think we had summit to eat
and it was just
i don't know it was just it was nice and
then we went on the big wheel as well
the ferris wheel
amanda fell in love with me the moment
she saw the shirt
oh my gosh i remember right
when because when i went to you met me
in the car park and when i saw him
i thought oh nice but the shirt that
samuel was wearing
oh my god i mean i've actually got a
picture we've got a picture from the
very first date that we had and i'll put
it in there neither of us look that good
on that picture no no yeah on the
picture yeah we we don't really
but yeah i was gonna i used to wear out
their clothes
like i used to wear you know stripey
shirts and colorful things yeah amanda
has slowly
sucked the color from my clothes but
left it in my personality so that's okay
yeah i wasn't feeling the [ __ ] um but we
haven't met before we met at the wedding
yeah like the month prior i remember as
well
well um when we met we were talking and
i said to her you know
because we've been speaking for hours
and we'd spoken before on the phone so i
kind of like asked her
where she was at in terms of
relationships um
of course she's single because she
wouldn't be with me on on that on that
day
where she and she said um she said right
now
i just want to spend some time with
the lord right she goes i just want to
find him
finding myself with the lord and i
thought that was her
way of saying this is a friend's date
you know like this is friends so when
she said that like i just want to spend
a bit of time now working on myself and
getting to know the lord better
i thought okay good great i just
finished bible college so i've been
to birmingham bible institute at new
college three years
studying theology and everything like
that she said i want to spend some time
finding the lord i thought fair enough
she's a wonderful person maybe this will
maybe we'll come back to this you know
in a couple years whatever and then as a
result of that
after the date um you said i was very
i'll give you a vote yeah so
he in his mind was thinking oh she just
wants to be friends because she's like
focusing on a walk with the lord at the
same time i
at the end of the day we spent the whole
day together
and i thought yeah well yeah right not
romantic
talking about life yeah we're getting to
know each other yeah and then at the end
of the day
he gave me a hug goodbye because she
went to hug me okay so he wasn't even
gonna hug me right
and then he like tapped me on the back
like that was it let's repeat that it
felt like a friend
and it was yeah and i just thought oh my
gosh i just thought okay he's totally
wanting to be friends because
he'd either try and kiss or at least try
and hug him for the first date you can't
try and throw
i mean i don't know i don't know i'm
just saying like it just
felt very friend vibes so we then left
and we both just thought
uh we're gonna be friends but we didn't
realize but i was thinking i really like
him
and you were thinking you really liked
me yeah but
yeah and then i think when we got home
that night we actually had the
conversation wasn't it
i don't know i don't remember what
happened next all i remember is suddenly
three kids came back
no we then yeah yeah
chatted more on the phone met up had a
long distance relationship for a long
time i know we used to literally spend
all night on the phone with each other
we'd wake we i'd go to sleep and the
birds would be singing yeah
we were just yeah i used to love that
and then our last date
was viewing a house what do you mean i
lost it
well yesterday was a date with oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah we're spending a
week together we've been together like
pretty much every single day amanda is
my permanent date life yeah
okay i have a question this is one two
three monday tuesday
i'm a single dad with two young
daughters
i would like to meet a new woman but i
don't want my kids to think i'm
replacing
their mother should i wait until they
are
teenagers
um i don't i mean someone in the
comments said i don't think samuel will
help you there
okay so let me answer the question so
you are single
you have kids i wouldn't wait today
no way would you no no
not if you meet someone that makes you
happy you know what in my in my opinion
okay we've got three kids
in my opinion you and people might hate
on me for this
maybe even amanda won't hate on me for
this but i don't think
you can dictate your whole world around
your kids
i just don't think that i think that you
live your life you have your kids and of
course it changes your world and things
but i i personally wouldn't do that in
terms
and again disclaimer i'm a property
coach
my opinion um but like my mom for
instance my parents divorced when i was
seven
and when my mom got in a new
relationship with tim
who weirdly was my school teacher
right so i was like oh this is i didn't
like it
but i think the thing is tim my mom's
new husband
rather than trying to be like a
replacement to my dad because i still
knew my dad
my dad was still my dad i had a good
relationship with him my
step-dad almost just acted like a friend
to me
so rather than trying to like discipline
me or he was just a friend
so my mom was my mom my dad was my dad
that i separated and my stepdad was just
a friend to me just cool
nice and over over the years at first i
had run-ins with him and stuff at times
but over time i just grew to respect him
as
look he is the homeowner of the house
that i live in i can't disrespect him
he's not my dad but he's married to my
mom he's a great guy he's kind to me
he's my
he's acts like a friend and he's kind of
the ruler of the house
right he is he's not the ruler of maybe
he's all over the house so i think
every setup is different but i
definitely wouldn't wait i would just
try and do it in the right way
i don't know what you have to say about
that yeah i think i mean i don't really
have anything more wiser than what you
said to add
but i think you're right i think as long
as the person's right and they don't try
and replace the kid's mom then i don't
really see the issue
yeah and and you know what you'll be the
best dad by being a happy dad yeah
so i'll send this to amanda i'm not sure
mandy let's go on the hot double every
single oh but the kids might be upset
because i'm not there i'm like you know
what the kids are going to be happy if
you're happy and you're going to be
happy in the hot tub
for just 20 minutes enjoying you know i
think it's really important to have
you time and and things yeah so speaking
as a young dad myself all right last
question
what is the difference between a
property millionaire
and a net millionaire
i was a property millionaire when we met
yeah you were
oh a net millionaire is when all of your
assets
minus all of your debts and liabilities
are equal to a million pounds
right right so if you've got a million
pounds worth of property but you've got
500 000 pounds worth of mortgages you're
not a millionaire
you might have a property portfolio
valued at a million pounds but you're
not a millionaire because you've got
debts
so you've got to add up all you own
and take away everything you owe and
that will leave your
net worth and if your net worth is less
than a million that
that's that's what it is so when we met
i had a portfolio worth a million pounds
but i had a lot of mortgages on them so
actually i wasn't a millionaire
i became a millionaire about a year
after we got married
because of amanda's great knowledge
about what a millionaire means
no actually food through deal sort of
thing yeah what was like
how crazy was life when we when we first
got married we were like literally
just on it with the like literally
finding houses left right and center
selling deals every day like crazy bang
bang bang
bang bang so so we had a portfolio which
we rented out and we're making a decent
living and everything was great we were
financially pretty secure
but we weren't cash millionaires
that came the year later when we did the
deal selling then we put the profits
back into property
and slowly over the last how long we've
been married six years six years yeah
what what about when we did the yeah six
years prop
we had two weddings so sometimes a bit
confusing african wedding english
wedding yeah i'm sure at some point
we'll talk about that
but anyway final words of wisdom oh
i don't have final words of wisdom this
week i don't got anything
oh my god oh my goodness
unprepared my final words of wisdom well
i guess what we talked about um
disconnect from negative people
who you're around is who you'll become
you know so get around good people
um and and and focus you know focus on
positive
focus on positivity and find yourself a
wonderful wonderful partner
to support you and make everything
happen anyway guys thanks so much for
watching or listening
and we'll see you next time